i'm here with tripp adler uh who is the
co-founder of scribd which rhymes with
ribbed and uh
which is explain exactly what scribd is
for people who don't use it
yeah um scribd is the world digital
library so we have a free service where
you can read unlimited books and
documents up to 40 million of them on
any device or you can pay 8.99 per month
and read unlimited premium books on
whatever device you like so most people
probably have come across your your
product
around the web and they got these big
long documents and they've used it for
free now this new this relatively new
thing is i can pay
nine dollars a month and i get access to
everything exactly so we um we're
building the subscription model for
books so we've partnered with over a
hundred publishers and have over a
hundred thousand uh best-selling books
new releases where you can pay one
monthly fee and then just read whatever
you like so rather than having to make a
purchase decision every single time you
want to read a book you can just pay for
access to the library and then and then
think about what to read not what to buy
and you you have a big deal with
harpercollins yeah so they're they're
one of the the big publishers we've
signed up and we have uh the majority of
their catalog and there's a lot of uh
great books in there by authors like
neil gaiman and paulo cuello that's
great and you started so you started
script right out you went to harvard you
graduated unlike many entrepreneurs and
then you
played around a little bit with
investment banking and then you decided
to start your own company
yeah so i i tried a number of things in
college i was pre-med for a little while
and then i ended up studying biophysics
i tried investing banking i worked in a
bunch of research labs and um i decided
i want to start my own company so i i
met my co-founder jared at harvard we we
tried a number of different ideas we
went to y combinator and then eventually
stumbled on scribd and what was the
original
idea
so the original idea um started when
talking to my dad who had a medical
paper he wanted to publish and in
medical publishing it takes about 18
months to publish a paper and he just
wanted to get the paper out there um so
we want to start a service that would
let him really easily take his paper and
publish it on the web and get it to his
colleagues um and then we started as a
publishing platform and over time we
realized that the main thing our
publishers wanted was more readers so
we've we've shifted our focus to
building more of a product for readers
and how many people use your product uh
we have about 80 million users wow and
you've grown very fast and you said
you're already profitable and your
revenues are in the tens of millions
yeah we've been uh nearly doubling
revenue year over year since we started
the company in 2007 and uh we've been
quite profitable for the last couple
years so you're no longer relying on
venture funding you're just funding it
out of the profits exactly yeah no we're
quite profitable so our challenge is now
is how to take our profits and reinvest
them to continue to grow our revenue so
if you look into the crystal ball into
the future and it's five years from now
we're sitting here what's going to be
different
um well i think we're going to be the
the same the same company right or the
same startup i mean it you know we
started the company six years ago and it
still feels a lot like it did early on
we're just bigger and have more people
and and more resources so um so i think
we'll be the same service um i think i
think we're going to have um a lot more
subscribers i think will will be the way
that that people read books in the
future i think subscribing to books will
be kind of the will be the norm and i
think um i think it will be the world's
digital library and i think will be more
than just books right we'll be the place
where you subscribe to read your
magazines where you read your scientific
papers where you get sheet music right
we want to be the world's digital
library where you can pay 8.99 per month
and find whatever content you want so we
really only have time for one more
question but this is one that's near and
dear to my heart so you said magazines
are going to be involved
so
are we going to have these paper objects
that we play with anymore in the future
or is that just not gonna happen
um yeah i think it'll it'll continue to
shift to digital um i don't think paper
is gonna completely go away i mean if
you look at even in music the the
supposedly record sales are coming back
so um so i think you're going to
continue to see print books but i think
digital will be continue to become more
and more important and i think the
concept of owning digital files will
become less important instead it'll
switch to an access model which is what
we're doing where you pay a fee and can
get access to the books rather than
actually own the files trip thank you so
much for your time thank you